[Music]
king arthur
is one of medieval britain's most famous
legends
since his time he's been depicted in
countless works of art
including novels tv shows movies but the
question
remains was he a real person or
completely made up
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives
a handful of experts discuss some of
history's earliest sources on a king
that was so mighty
a lot of folks don't believe he ever
really existed
we begin now by examining the historical
context of the world that gave rise
to king arthur enjoy
if we're going to understand who king
arthur really was we have to understand
the historical context
which means we have to go all the way
back to the last days of the roman
empire back to the moment when the
ancient world in europe
was just starting to transform into the
medieval one
in 406 a.d there was an unusually cold
winter
and the rhine river froze
large numbers of barbarians from
northern europe simply
walked across the river into roman
territory
and raided all over the roman province
of gaul
this was a threat to the security of
rome itself
so emperor anorius decided on a fateful
step
he ordered the roman legions in britain
to withdraw to the continent
and he told the residents of britain
essentially you're on your own
the romans left britain in 410 as we've
seen
it was perhaps a generation or so later
when the anglo-saxons
began to arrive we don't know how many
arrived
was it just relatively small bands of
warriors or
a full-scale army albeit a somewhat
ragged one
did they bring their wives and children
we don't know
what we can be sure of is that they came
from a wide
geographical area from northern germany
southern denmark southern scandinavia
and the southern frisian coast
that's to say the the coastline to the
northeast of france
they didn't immediately assert
themselves as a culture
the first to arrive were nomads
primarily interested in
plunder by the end of the fifth century
however
they had begun to establish settlements
in much of the east
and the south of what later came to be
called
in their honor england
so what did you do when the anglo-saxons
started arriving did you put up a
spirited
resistance well yes you certainly did if
there's any
truth to the arthur legend it was
king arthur so the story goes who
valiantly defended britain
against the invaders around 500
he defeated them at an unidentified site
called
mons badonicus gildas was a british
writer
a christian who wrote about the history
of britain during the period of
barbarian settlement
he says that at the end of the 5th
century a great war leader emerged who
fought 12
great battles against the barbarians the
last of these battles
at mount baden was a great victory that
halted the advance of the barbarians for
50 years
that is right up to the time when gildas
was writing
when things were obviously getting bad
again
this statement by gilda seems to be the
earliest evidence we have
for the existence of the figure who
later became known
as king arthur it's not a lot to go on
gildas calls this person a war leader
not a king
and in fact the way he talks about him
makes it clear that there
are other people who are kings and that
this guy
isn't one of them and he doesn't give
him the name
arthur or in fact any other name
in fact the earliest use of the name
arthur
comes in a 6th century poem from the
north of britain called igor doden
which is written in an early form of
celtic this passage is about a great
warrior named guardr
who we are told quote pierced over 300
of the finest
he struck at both the center and the
flank he was worthy in the front of a
most generous army
he gave out gifts from his herd of
steeds in the winter
he fed black ravens on the wall of a
fortress
though he was not arthur among the
powerful in battle
in the van an alder shield wall gwarther
that's it one line though he was not
arthur
the clear meaning here is twofold one
everybody already knows who arthur is so
the poet doesn't even need to explain
this to the audience
it would be like going to church on
sunday and having the priest or minister
need to explain to everyone present
there's this guy called jesus the second
thing to note is that this guarder guy
is totally incredible
good with a sword generous to the people
around him
he's an all-around awesome leader and
yet he pales
in comparison to arthur but did arthur
really exist no one knows for certain
it's possible the brits invented him to
make themselves
feel less bad about being a conquered
race
after all it would have been greatly
comforting to tell your children
that their fathers and forefathers had
put up a heroic resistance to the
invasion
and had even come close to victory
before being overwhelmed by the sheer
force of numbers
and in time you would have believed the
legend yourself
the truth of the matter however is that
despite what gilda says
we don't know for certain whether we
should be thinking primarily
in terms of a war-like invasion or of an
essentially
peaceful settlement nor do we know
to what extent there was intermarriage
between the british
and the anglo-saxon invaders or to what
extent the native population was
forced to retreat westwards to escape
the anglo-saxon advance
and encroachment on their land
a 9th century writer named nanius said
that arthur fought 12 battles
but we aren't sure where they were still
there is some evidence in the
archaeological record that there was
indeed
a 50-year halt in the advance of
germanic settlement in britain
on the borders of the southeastern
kingdom of kent
saxon pottery went out of use for a time
so perhaps we have some confirmation
here of the essential truth of the story
could that halt have been caused by this
war leader
who may or may not have been called
arthur
let's review the evidence and assess the
arguments
the facts as we know them could support
the idea of a famous war leader
not a king who stemmed the tide of the
germanic advance in britain
maybe he was even named arthur but there
are some
important cautions to keep in mind we
cannot be sure that the person guild ass
describes and the person mentioned in
the poem about the godothan
are the same we don't have any evidence
about that
one way or the other it may be that
nenes had good reason to think they were
the same
but he may just have put the two texts
side by side and made a great
big assumption which people down to the
present day have been making
ever since we also can't be sure that
the pause and settlement that we seem to
see
in the archaeological record was caused
by the activity of the war leader that
guild ass mentions
there are plenty of other factors that
could have caused a temporary halt
in migration changes in the political
situation back on the continent
maybe a lack of leadership any number of
other causes and again
the archaeological record doesn't really
support an idea of large-scale military
activity at this time
we don't have 12 battlefields to go with
nene's 12 battles
certainly some of the native population
withdrew from the lowlands of england to
wales and the west country that's to say
to
the counties of somerset devon and
cornwall
the part below wales that sticks out
into the atlantic
like the leg of a seated man we know
that
because these counties experienced a
substantial increase in population
as the result of the influx of refugees
and as the british withdrew they took
with them
their belief in christianity along with
the
vestiges of roman culture including
their knowledge of latin both
christianity and latin survived in the
monasteries which they established
particularly around the coast
in fact the seat of arthur's power was
identified with
tintagel a castle on the north coast of
cornwall
if arthur lived any place perhaps he
lived at tintagel
which is a very impressive early
medieval fortress that still survives
tintagel seems to have functioned as an
actual royal center for the kingdom of
demonia
we'll probably never know for sure about
this but it has been
fabulous for tourism you'll find hotels
and restaurants in tintagel
called things like king arthur's castle
hotel and
camelot now tintagel is a
breathtaking sight on the cornish coast
and if you look at the headland there
you can see how easily defensible it is
the one
passageway from the mainland to the
outcropping where the castle once stood
is wide enough to accommodate at most
three people abreast and there's really
no other access unless you swim in and
scale the cliffs
for a long time the arthurian
associations with the area were thought
to be just romantic hearsay
but then archaeological investigations
proved
that maybe this is not the case the site
was occupied in the 5th and 6th
centuries
and it was occupied by an important and
very wealthy
wealthy leader judging by pottery and
other goods discovered there
this was actually quite a cosmopolitan
community
and they seem to have engaged in lots of
long-distance trade all the way
throughout the mediterranean
all of this was exciting and suggestive
enough
but then in 1998 investigators made a
discovery
that seemed even more conclusive in
terms of an arthurian connection
to the place of tintagel so while
excavating
this one site that had been confirmed as
being intact from the 6th century so it
was securely dated and
it was clear that it hadn't been
tampered with in the centuries since
the archaeologist flipped over a stone
and they discovered a carving on it
in what looks to be authentic sixth
century latin
and that carving says something like
pattan
coley
which translated into english means
something like
artogno father of a descendant of
call made this there were several
scholars of course who issued very
cautionary words one pointed out that
just because a name has art in it
doesn't mean it must refer to arthur any
more
than a person named gerald could be said
to be the same as the famous native
american warrior
geronimo but at the same time what is
important about this discovery and the
other archaeological finds
is that it confirms there was a powerful
ruler
operating out of tintagel at exactly the
time the legend
says this was the case
there are some other tantalizing pieces
of evidence suggesting that in this time
and place
which is late 5th to early 6th century
britain in the areas in the south and
the west
what we might call out of an i would say
overly abundant uh measure of caution
there is a guy who's an arthur type
figure and he emerges
as a leader of the native celts against
the anglo-saxon invaders
one of the other sites that confirms
this fact is a place that's known as
cadbury hill or cadbury castle
and it has often been referred to as
camelot by the locals and it's been
called that as far as anyone can tell
from time out of mind archaeologists
expected that they would find
pretty much the same thing at other iron
age hill forts
in other words they expected they'd find
abandonment during the roman years
then re-occupation in the face of the
anglo-saxon onslaught
but guess what nope not a one
to this day no other hill fort
has shown signs of reoccupation during
what we might call the
sub-roman or even arthurian age
of britain what's
more the excavations of cadbury hill
reveal that this was
not some small desperate group of
persecuted people
fleeing and then hiding out until the
anglo-saxon menace had passed
what we have on the top of cadbury hill
is
not so much a retreat or an escape
as it is an actual center of operations
for a well-organized resistance
the best estimates give us
the figure of a community of over 700
people
who were serving both military and
support functions
now although the main structures
disappointingly
for many of us were not the massive
stone edifices that immediately come to
mind when we say the word camelot today
the wooden palisades and great hall on
cadbury hill
were quite significant feats of
engineering and construction
for that particular period especially
when we consider that the average war
band
in celtic britain included something
like
30 to 40 people so the average war band
30 to 40 people
this war band at least 700.
so somebody in the right time
and place to be arthur was able to
command
a remarkable degree of loyalty from
quite a large group of people
he was obviously able to manage all
kinds of difficult logistics ranging
from
combat strategy to feeding clothing and
housing his men
and probably their families and he was
able to do it
for a significant stretch of time and
this is what's really
important it was probably decades even
and then there's the most impressive
feat
this guy managed to stay alive
so he had to be a true warrior because
in this time and in this place and in
this situation
the leader of a group did not sit at
home
while he worked out some strategy and
then sent his troops in to do the actual
fighting
for most of this period whoever the
leader of the operation at cadbury hill
was
he was right there on the front lines
right in the thick of it this guy the
more you think about it
you have to realize he was truly
remarkable
if he wasn't actually called arthur he
most certainly served as the foundation
on which
later elements of the legend were
layered
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about any of the topics in
this episode
the full list of series that these clips
came from is in the description below
you can watch all the full series now on
onedream.com and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube
channel turn on notifications and you'll
get an alert every time we post a new
episode of perspectives